[Musique]
un décor qui rappellerait presque les
aventuriers de l'arche perdue ce temple
égyptien c'est la fierté de son créateur
inspiré des temples de fil à et de
louxor
il comporte environ 5000 pièces de lego
quatre années de travail et de recherche
ont été nécessaires pour le réaliser
j'ai commencé par modélisés avec
différents logiciels
une première ébauche du temps pour
savoir les petits bleus qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait acheter les quantités et après
donc j'ai commencé par construire toute
la partie avant la façade je continue
bien sûr sur tout le reste
et au fur et à mesure j'ai amélioré
puisque au début le temple était plein
donc maintenant il est ouvert sur les
côtés pour qu'on puisse voir l'intérieur
les lego une passion commencé dès
l'enfance devenu un travail à part
entière président de l'association
breezy rémy organise une exposition
dédiée aux petites briques danoises
il se prépare pour le concours c'est un
petit module on appelle la vigne est
donc le but de représenter dans un
format assez réduit donc c'est le public
qui va voter pour le
la meilleure vignette parmi les
exposants le thème c'est de représenter
un sport et celle ci va représenter de
l'escaladé une trentaine de passionnés
feront découvrir leur travail
une exposition pour les petits comme
pour les grands enfants